[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from Liverpool on the day a man is
found guilty for the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell
Olivia's family celebrated the verdict
today seven months after she was shot
and killed while in her own home
Thomas Cashman arrested in September
last year will be sentenced on Monday
he's a coward he's despicable
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial
questions tonight about crime in this
city we hear from an ex-gang member from
Liverpool
I was mentioning North share course I
was mentioned in all situations so I'm a
bit of a hypocrite to stand the announce
I you know that after it's gone which
they are but I was one I was once that
same Stromberg
also tonight on Sky News at 10.
allegations of bullying harassment and
discrimination in every fire and rescue
service in England
the government defends its Net Zero
strategy over concerns the UK will fall
behind on the race to a green economy
and
does kerning
the king makes history at the German
Parliament speaking in German and
renewing the pledge of friendship
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
well good evening live from Liverpool
Thomas Cashman a self-confessed drug
dealer was found guilty today of the
murder of Olivia Pratt Corbell the
nine-year-old was killed at her home
here in Liverpool in August last year
after Cashman fired gunshots into her
family's home Olivia's mother who
watched the verdict at Manchester Crown
Court said she was ecstatic with the
news in a moment we'll look at what
happened in the hours before the gun was
fired but first here's my report
in the dark on a Liverpool Street these
were the moments that were to lead to
tragedy Thomas Cashman marked by police
with a blue dot pursuing his intended
victim a man called Joseph knee marked
here in red
the gunfire recorded on a security
camera and shown to the jury it was the
next shot that was to prove fatal to a
young girl
Olivia Pratt Corbell was just nine years
old a unique chatty nosy little girl her
family said Who Loved life and all it
had to offer it was a life cut short by
a gunman who'd gone out to kill
a jury deciding that that gunman was
Cashman whose ruthless Pursuit took the
shooting inside Olivia's home
what Olivia's mother Cheryl made of the
verdict was clear to see as she left
court she and her family sat through the
trial for them and for police a moment
of relief
the circumstances around it were just
abundance
and she was cowering behind them all
because she was scared in her own home
he always feel as though you're safe in
your own house
I think as an investigation team we
could not believe
that the government would continue to
shoot into the house
I don't think we've ever seen anything
like that before
the community had been discoursed
by his actions
they've been in fear of him for a long
long time
he will know himself
and have to carry that responsibility
Olivia's mum Cheryl was injured by the
bullet that killed her daughter the jury
heard her description of that night the
moment she knew Olivia in her words was
gone
this was that intended target that night
convicted burglar knee police say it was
a petty dispute
Cashman had denied being the gunman he
said he was going about his business as
a high-level cannabis dealer that night
but the trial heard from a witness who
said he'd gone to her home after the
shooting looking for a change of clothes
and admitting having done Joey knee
police have commended her bravery in
coming forward at no time police say as
Cashman shown any remorse he's a coward
he's despicable
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial I hope he reflects every
morning when he wakes up behind bars and
every night when he goes to sleep
about what he's put Olivia's family
through
the guns used at night have still not
been recovered police say this
investigation continues even after a
lengthy and complex prosecution
all over Olivia's family and her loved
ones I can't imagine what they will have
been through over the last few weeks
compounded of course by the fact that he
refused to take responsibility or plead
guilty at court
nothing is going to bring Olivia back
but I do hope that this offers some
level of comfort for the family that we
have been able to secure Justice and he
is now facing a life sentence
Cashman was driven away from court but
will be back there on Monday to be
sentenced police say Olivia's death
should not be in vain a girl of wit and
kindness her family said whose life was
short but whose personality certainly
wasn't
well during the trial the prosecution
detailed Thomas cashman's movements on
Monday the 22nd of August 2022.
making multiple Journeys throughout the
day Thomas Cashman returned to his house
for eight minutes before leaving again
at 8 30 p.m he drove around the local
area before parking his car and walking
to Finch Lane where he waited for more
than 30 minutes for Joseph knee
Joseph knee was at an address on Finch
Lane watching a football match with a
friend which finished at 9 52 shortly
afterwards knee left the house with his
friend and turned on to King's Heath
Avenue
CCTV footage captured Joseph knee being
pursued by Thomas Cashman at 9 59. shots
were fired
Joseph knee then ran into the driveway
of the Corbell house Thomas Cashman
fired into the house this was the moment
Olivia Pratt Corbell was shot Thomas
Cashman fled the scene running through
back Gardens Joseph knee was picked up
by a car
well after Olivia's murder police in
Liverpool made several arrests but it
took more than a month before any
charges were brought it was thought that
a gang culture created fear among the
community Sky's Martin brunt has been
speaking to a former gang member about
organized crime in the city
we got into firearms and guns for 21.
and then just escalated us from there
sicarius McGrath was a major Liverpool
gangster he once roamed these streets
where guns are used to enforce drug
Empires I was mentioning all share cause
I was mixing in those situations so I'm
a bit of a hypocrite to stand here now
and say you know their absolutely to
come which they are but I was one I was
once that same scumbag and you put guns
on the streets by your own admission I
think in massive volumes
when Olivia was shot the community was
in Conflict outrage balanced against
loyalty and fear of being called a grass
probably people are going to be in
Oakland and I think depend on who
commits the mayor that if they're
established gang members then people are
going to be more reluctant police
struggle to get the evidence they needed
for Olivia's murder
everyone says there's a Code no question
no no this no doubt if it benefits can
most they will they will grasp each
other up it's what benefits them they're
not just going to do for charity but for
the members of the public who witness a
big crime how difficult is it for them
do you think to give information it's
going to be a woman it's going to be
scary and they're not really going to
want to get involved but when it's a
child I think the real big goes out to
win them but they will worry weren't
they about their own safety afterwards
if people find out that's for the police
to go nobody but that's what the police
to to reassure them that they're gonna
protect them and ensure their safety
police heard from one key witness early
on that got no direct evidence no one
who could identify the gunman no
forensics no weapon a reward of 50 000
pounds wasn't doing the trick it was
boosted with another hundred thousand
from an anonymous donor a businessman
from merseyside the charity topped it up
to a record 200 000 pounds when I heard
there was a reluctance for people to
come forward and testify that's what
really got my back up I thought well I'm
going to do something about this it was
an amount that would make people sit up
and take notice the bottom line is that
this was horrific the murder of a young
girl it doesn't come much worse than
that 16 years ago a young boy Rhys Jones
was shot dead only a few miles from here
I reported on it sicarius was in prison
but we both heard the loud calls for
change
they always say that whenever there's a
young person stabbed or shot
and they say enough is enough and
they're going to take Istanbul
communities never do it's just all words
a couple of days or a couple weeks later
they just go back to doing what he was
doing and forget about it it's only the
families that are left suffering
last August Olivia's death was one of
three gun murders in a week
there have been two more in the city
since
well Martin's here with me now and
Martin we have that conviction now and
the focus
moves I suppose to Monday and sentencing
and what we can expect from that
well he's been convicted of murder on
one of those five charges so that's an
automatic life imprisonment sentence the
issue for the judge will be to decide
the minimum number of years that he'll
have to serve the Tariff
um and I imagine that's going to be
pretty high I mean there are lots of
things
for her to consider and of course we'll
get all of her thinking because we
believe the sentence is going to be
broadcast live you know one of the the
first few since last year so that would
be fascinating to see how she balances
things
um
I suppose one of the big issues is that
he didn't intend to kill Olivia I mean I
think by anybody's judgment but he did
intend to kill his real Target Joseph
Lee the man he was chasing and who he
shot just before he fired the bullet
that killed Olivia so that will be part
of her calculation he's convicted of
attempting murder that too can carry a
maximum of life imprisonment
um I imagine that the judge will
probably give him
at least 30 years other factors these
Show No Remorse the age of his victim
the fact that he was virtually
terrorizing a community with what he did
all of that means a pretty long minimum
sentence before he'll get a chance of
parole all right we'll find out on
Monday afternoon Martin thank you very
much it's been an emotionally charged
day here in Liverpool this is how the
news is being received here tonight on
the front page of the Liverpool Echo the
local newspaper here their headline
Justice for our Olivia and I think the
city really you get a census breathe the
sigh of relief as a result of what
happened at Manchester Crown Court today
as a trial they followed very closely
the trial was moved from Liverpool to
Manchester because they were concerned
at just how strong the feelings were in
Liverpool and whether that trial could
be carried out fairly here but they've
been watching very closely uh what what
has happened as I say the community
around Olivia's family the whole city I
think breathing that sigh of relief and
I think most people's Thoughts with
Olivia's family tonight as they confront
what they will have to confront for the
for the rest of their lives
okay Greg and Martin in a Liverpool
thank you for now now environmental
groups have suggested they could once
again take legal action against the
government over its Net Zero plan a
30-page document called powering up
Britain has been published and covers
everything from electric vehicles to
sustainable Finance despite this there
is a real worry the UK is falling too
far behind in the race to a green
economy our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports
the Prime Minister and Energy Secretary
Grant shaps at the UK's National nuclear
fusion research lab here to launch a
plan explaining how we will increase
energy security while also cutting
carbon emissions to Net Zero behind the
smiles though there is real pressure
building on this issue with America
launching a huge green subsidies package
to tempt investors over the Atlantic
your Chancellor Jeremy Hunt has said
today that it is a distortive global
subsidies race hasn't it cost us the
UK's lead on wind not yet and I'm
concerned that it doesn't or that it
shouldn't over the last decade or more
we've spent 50 more as a proportion of
our GDP than America on Renewables I
welcome the fact that America have
finally woken up to the opportunities
here and I hope we're going to sell a
lot of stuff too the criticism is that
the policies you announced today are
really just about Target setting and
framework and you are closing your eyes
and hoping the market is going to do the
rest
could not disagree more this this
country has a huge lead in
decarbonization that one of our European
neighbors can match by the way and
America is a decade behind the
government's plan explains that it wants
to phase out fossil fuels almost
entirely by replacing them with more
nuclear and Renewable Power there's also
help for consumers to reduce Demand with
expanded Home Heating and installation
schemes and there's more investment in
clean Technologies
the problem with some of the
technologies that feature significantly
in the government's plans is that
they're relatively untested hydrogen
small nuclear reactors carbon capture
and storage none of these things are
affordable yet or available at scale
and despite a court order forcing the
government to reveal more detail on its
Net Zero targets some critics say the
plan is short on new policies and new
cash
it isn't enough as it stands how are we
going to make sure that we get off gas
for heating as quickly as possible and
onto electric Technologies is the money
that they've promised for insulation
enough to really help people with their
bills in the long run so this is a step
on but it's not the whole journey
but others at the sharp end of the Green
Revolution are happy with the progress
absolutely massive news for our business
and for everyone around the country
we're in a an energy crisis we're in a
cost of living places so the government
investment and Energy Efficiency and
retrofit is massively welcomed by us
promises are one thing but now Net Zero
must actually be delivered a task
growing more complicated by the day
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
now the government has been warned it is
lagging behind the likes of the US and
the European Union on its Net Zero
Ambitions as companies choose to invest
their own green strategies elsewhere our
business correspondent Paul Kelso has
been looking at how the UK compares if
the UK is going to cut carbon emissions
hit Net Zero targets and deliver energy
security it's going to need the green
industries that will deliver the energy
transition and transform the economy so
what's the government promised to make
that happen well there's 20 billion
pounds over 20 years to explore carbon
capture now that's an unproven
technology but it could take emissions
from polluting Industries and bury them
beneath the North Sea they promised 240
million pounds for green hydrogen which
could decarbonize some industrial
processes and another billion for home
insulation which could cut demand and
there's half a billion for wind farm
development and electric vehicle
charging now almost all of this money
had already been announced but it still
sounds like quite a lot right well not
compared to the huge subsidy programs
launched in the United States and Europe
last August Joe Biden announced the
inflation reduction act a 369 billion
dollar pack age for green Industrial
Development the European Union plans 250
billion euros of its own subsidies to
try and keep some of those Industries in
Europe now faced with this transatlantic
arm wrestle for green Industrial
Development Chancellor Jeremy Hunt has
effectively conceded the UK can't
compete and wants to make up for being
smaller by being smarter this is what he
told the times we are not going
toe-to-toe with our friends and allies
in some distortive Global subsidy race
we will Target Public Funding in a
strategic way now part of the plan is to
harness the financial clout of the city
of London hunt says reforms for the way
insurers are allowed to invest could
free up a hundred billion pounds for
Green Technology over the next decade
but to put that in perspective the
treasury thinks the energy transition
will need up to 600 billion pounds of
capital investment over the same period
and Industry says the UK has just been
too slow to respond
I think I think private capital is very
important you need government to create
the framework to enable private Capital
to invest but we need the policies we
need the framework in some of the
discussions that have
um been announced today especially
around the planning rules and things
like that that will build investor
confidence the investment climate has
become a little clearer today and there
are huge opportunities in the green
transition but business investors and
environmentalists remain skeptical that
this package does enough to deliver
Britain's climate goals
all right let's just bring you some
breaking news that's coming to us in the
last few minutes here at Sky News and
concerns NATO and the war in Ukraine the
Turkish Parliament have voted to allow
Finland to join the military Alliance
you'll remember that both Finland and
Sweden had asked to join NATO following
Russia's invasion of Ukraine last year
that uh Ascension to the group was being
held up by turkey and also by Hungary
but the Turkish Parliament have now
voted to allow Finland to join NATO
following on from the Hungarian
Parliament which voted to ratify
finland's attempt to join the military
Alliance earlier this week so now just
Sweden it's the outstanding Nordic
Nation trying to join the military
Alliance and more pressure will now be
going on both Turkish Parliament and the
Hungarian one to allow Sweden to join
more on that story as we get it
throughout the evening now a report here
has found that there are allegations of
bullying harassment and discrimination
in every fire and rescue service in
England the fire inspect which said some
examples include joking about the rape
of female colleagues and using racial
slurs well the home office has said that
it is deeply concerned by the findings
and that it will continue to work
closely with fire and Rescue Services to
make sure the issues are urgently
addressed well Sky News has spoken to
one serving female firefight about her
experiences in the service and a warning
that this report by Sadia Chaudhary has
detailed descriptions of sexual
harassment delegations and explicit
images
it seems so Brazen the way this
firefighter takes a photo of himself it
looks like he's at work he's even in
uniform
and he's not the only one we spoke to
the woman who was sent these images
I try and avoid people that have sent me
pictures like that now and I try and act
as normal as possible but it's always at
the back of my mind
a lot of sexual favors asked for a
female colleague was pinned in the
corner by more than one firefighter and
demanded sexual favors another was
sexually assaulted by a colleague as he
walked past then he took photos of her
changing
has anything like that ever happened to
you yes I hadn't discussed it before but
there was a time after an evening out
that I did get pressured into sleeping
with a colleague when I didn't want to
if I was sober I would never have
consented to it after that my mental
health was really bad
I actually I regretted it so much that I
let myself get that drunk
I didn't expect to get upset last year I
actually made an attempt to take my own
life because of how he made me feel
it is these types of stories that his
Majesty's inspectorate warns about
bullying harassment
discrimination bad behavior often
dismissed as banter and victims too
scared to come forward
the report is damning not just for fire
Services here in London but in every
part of England and some of the examples
are really disturbing a senior officer
referring to a black colleague using a
racial slur and on another occasion two
male firefighters joked with a female
colleague that they were going to rape
her before the three of them play acted
that rape out
inspectors say that is just the
beginning I can't guarantee this is not
the tip of the iceberg I can't guarantee
there's not Predators or races
homophobes sexist within the fire rescue
service but what I can guarantee that if
our recommendations are implemented
things will improve
those recommendations include new
misconduct standards to be introduced
there are also calls for a national Bard
list and background checks on every
firefighter and staff anyone found unfit
could lose their job the home office
described the report's findings as
deeply concerning a spokesperson said we
have been clear in our recent proposals
that fire reform is urgently needed we
want to see fire and Rescue Services
where everyone is welcome treated with
respect and able to thrive
it needs to change all over the guys
that don't report things when they see
it are the ones that aren't helping
everyone else because cases just get
dropped on a balance of probabilities
this Fearless profession she says has
been left too scared to speak Saudia
chowdry Sky News
now if you've been affected by any of
the issues raised inside his report you
can contact the Samaritans on 116 123 or
you can text shouts to eight five two
five eight
now the labor party have launched their
local election campaign so kirstama
describes the Prime Minister as Mr one
percent and said that a labor government
would freeze council tax the local
elections are just over a month away and
may offer an indication as to whether
the labor party's poll lead can be
turned into votes now in an interview
with our political editor Beth Rigby the
labor leader confirmed he's prepared to
do what it takes to win here's her
report
the next prime minister of this country
kirst armor that's the hope now the hard
yards Labor's leader today embracing the
task ahead and looking like he means
business these elections really really
matter and we've got to go out and we've
got to win them to do that Starman needs
to secure Council seats in Swindon and
Beyond calling on the government to
freeze council tax as he kicks off his
local election campaign
but the path to the general election
already firmly on his mind important
moment for you in the quest to win a
general election right yeah they are
they're very important
um for a number of reasons when you come
out of these local elections on May the
5th what does Victory look like well
look we want to take everything we
possibly can in these local elections
they're very very important to us but
I'm measuring this on the road into the
next general election you've got to show
you're in serious contention I'm putting
it to you that what I'm looking at is
whether you can get over a thousand
seats is that fair well look we want to
get as many of those thousand seats as
we possibly can I'm measuring the
progress from the general election 2019
to the general election in 2024. the
2019 general election under Jeremy
corbyn Labor's worst performance in over
80 years this labor lead of preventing
his predecessor from standing at the
next a drastic attempt to close the
corbyn chapter for good you described
German Corbin is your friend and now
you've kicked him out as one person who
is responsible for the fact that Jeremy
corbyn will not be a labor candidate of
the next election and that's Jeremy
corbyn you're prepared to be ruthless to
win I'm prepared to be ruthless to
ensure that we have a labor government I
have been ruthless in the change in the
labor party but people here are not yet
fully convinced I think they're going to
win the council I think there's a real
hope that they will yeah but like many
towns there's a big divide and
lots of people I think still will vote
for careful it comes across as well
trustworthy but the proof of the pudding
is so you're in government is it to me
there's an awful lot of show but I don't
hear them coming up with a remedy
fix what he's talking about
this campaign firmly underway but
there's still a lot of ground yet to
gain and time to go Beth Rigby Sky News
in Swindon
now authorities in the U.S city of
Nashville have released recordings of
the 9-1-1 calls made by those fleeing
Monday's mass shooting at an elementary
school six people including three
children were shot dead by Audrey
Elizabeth Hale a former student a U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports
let's go
body cam images have taken us inside the
Covenant School as a horror unfolded now
there is audio of emergency 9-1-1 calls
that may bear the fear panic and
confusion and staff and pupils hid from
a killer in the building
one was from an adult she says she was
hiding in an art room closet she hears
gunfire and tells children with her to
be quiet
are you in a safe spot right now
are you hearing shots now
no
closet
okay
yes I hear another shot you did hearing
more shots okay okay we're upstairs in
the hallway
you're upstairs by one hallway
in the art room art room yes please
hurry up you're coming they're coming
can you just try okay try to stay quiet
I don't know what's going on there but
um another call is made by adults
escaping the school one provides a
description of the killer in camouflage
I also was a man holding an assault
rifle shoot into the door okay it was
here he's currently in the second grade
hallway second grade stairs okay
man well I guess camouflage the best gun
in a assault rifle camouflage on
Thursday saw a protest for stricter gun
control at the Tennessee State
Legislature emotions are raw here the
more they learn about the murder in
their midst the more it amplifies their
call for change
James Matthews Sky News Washington
a serving metropolitan police officer
could face criminal charges over the
fatal shooting of Chris Kaba Mr Kaba was
killed by a single shot fired through
the windscreen of the car he was
traveling in in September last year the
independent office for police conduct
has referred the case to the crown
prosecution service
the White House has said that it is
deeply concerned after a reporter from
The Wall Street Journal was arrested in
Russia on suspicion of spying the
Federal Security Service says that Evan
gerskovich was detained in the city of e
catalinaburg while allegedly trying to
obtain a classified information
King Charles has become the first
British monarch to address Germany's
Parliament as the queen consort looked
on he talked of a special bond between
the two countries and the pride he felt
in the partnership and he delivered the
majority of his speech in German our
Royal correspondent Laura bundock was
there
to depact Parliament this was a moment
for the Monarch to deliver
and for 23 minutes that's what he did it
gives me particular pride to be with you
once again now as king
and to renew the special bond of
friendship between our two countries
the in German he talked of World War II
and the late Queen's role renewing
relations
foreign
is thus the grunt varum see Sikh einen
Platts
in Hudson the deutschen Roberta from
past conflicts to current and strong
words on Ukraine
the angris creek
and there was light relief too from
football to Monty Python and perhaps
most importantly for the last 50 years
we have loved together
both at each other and with each other
the first British monarch to address the
bundestad and for the chamber he'd met
the moment
delivered in both English and German The
King's Speech felt personal this was a
message of historic friendship and
Alliance no mention of brexit or
division it is the UK looking forward
and focusing on the future
the king is known for his concern about
Ukraine and to that he visited this
Immigration Center helping those who
recently fled
the day's other engagements in tune with
the themes of this visit celebrating
culture
and building bridges in more ways than
one the king with this joint German and
British army unit
but perhaps most relaxed here getting a
feel for Germany's organic farming Laura
bundock Sky News in Berlin